depuis 1960 le festival du film il y a
eu tellement de remue ménage dans la
carte du cinématographique de montréal
que nous avons pensé en 1963 que le
temps était mûr pour jeter les bases de
ce qui existe dans la plupart des
grandes capitales du monde c'est à dire
une cinémathèque musique cinéma
cinémathèque ça joue un rôle très
important parce que c'est là qu'on y
retrouve les vieux films et les films
qui même aujourd'hui ont une valeur
actuelle pour le spectateur est il ici à
montréal de plus en plus de cinéastes
moi même j'en suis un jeune
organisateurs russes aussi un cinéaste
qui veulent aller puiser dans l'histoire
du cinéma
tout comme d'ailleurs les critiques
veulent aller voir les vieux films tout
comme on lit la littérature enfin
participer un peu à l'évolution du
langage de ses talents et qui ne peuvent
pas aller voir les films ne sont pas ici
on n'a pas de structure n'est ce pas on
n'a pas d'organisme qui les montent ou
même qui les conserve et c'est pour cela
un peu nous avons pensé cette année que
il fallait commencer cela tout comme
d'autres ont commencé les festivals où
on commençait des revues de cinéma les
amuser de cinéma mais pas qu une
cinémathèque
qu'est ce que vous ignorez outre les
pellicules bien évidemment il les
pellicules elles mêmes doivent être
conservés n'est ce pas elles doivent
être gardés dans des voûtes
mais il ya aussi ce qu'on peut appeler
une salle de musée où on retrouve des
vieux projecteurs on a déjà des diffuse
appareils des scénarios des costumes les
décors des photos nous avons par exemple
déjà un projecteur de qui date de 1896
qui était retrouvé ici même à montréal
dans une gamme c'était très poussiéreux
et ce projecteur a sûrement servi autant
du oui mettent au scope on apprend une
caméra de 1906 fabrication française qui
assure mme a filmé le départ des troupes
canadiennes pendant la première grande
guerre
on a même une énorme projecteur powers
madame 1906 qui a l'air de ces deux
monstres sur pied n'est ce pas et qui
servait jusqu'à ces dernières années au
collège de l'assomption a donné des
représentations
cinématographique au collège n'est ce
pas ça fait 7 aces beaucoup des gens de
voir comme le cinéma et jeunes et vieux
à la fois on a aussi des choses comme la
table de travail de norman mclaren qu'il
a fait construire juste des planches de
bois dans les classes et un artisan il a
fait construire une table de travail
avec un tout n'est ce pas où il peut
placer une lumière et voir le film la
pellicule et qu'il dessine lui-même et
c'est sur cette table 50 75 ou de bois
qu'il a dessiné la plupart des petites
bandes annonces et des films qui ont
dernier des prix dans les grands
festivals internationaux pour nous sa
valeur de symbole si vous voulez n'est
ce pas et c'est une chose qui doit se
retrouver dans un musée est-ce que vous
avez d'autres objets peter est ce que
vous savez que vince cuse guitariste que
symbolique que nous avons les
authentiques ciseaux de l'ancien censure
des films qui ont été achetés en 1918 et
qui ont servi jusqu'à l'an passé n'est
ce pas à couper les films ça aussi c'est
un c'est un objet symbolique que le fait
qu'il se sait si zola se retrouve
aujourd'hui dans un musée de cinéma et
témoigne un peu aussi de l'évolution de
la société canadienne française et de
son attitude beaucoup plus positive
envers le cinéma et envers les idées
ingénieurs